act accordingly nobody knows what the
number of fatalities may end up being
the number of people who may get ill and
we all hope that that number will be as
low as possible
but we also have to face the truth and
that is that the number of casualties
may actually be even higher and what the
Armed Forces experienced in World War
two in other words we have a major major
crisis and we must act accordingly
therefore it is a absolute moral
imperative that our response as a
government as a society as a business
community and as individual citizens
meet the enormity of this crisis as
people stay or work from home and are
directed to quarantine it will be easy
for us to feel like we are all alone I'm
working at home not at my office or that
we must only worry about ourselves and
think that everybody else should fend
for themselves
but in my view that would be a tragic
and dangerous mistake if there ever was
a time in the modern history of our
country when we are all in this together
this is that moment now is the time for
solidarity now is the time to come
together with love and compassion for
all including the most vulnerable people
in our society who will face this
pandemic from the health perspective
will pace the face it from an economic
perspective if our neighbor or co-worker
get sick
we have the potential to become sick if
our neighbor loses his or her job then
our local community suffers and we may
lose our jobs we are in this together if
doctors and nurses and medical personnel
do not have the equipment and the
training and the capacity they need
right now people we know make
unnecessarily face additional illness
and even death we are all in this
together unfortunately in this time of
international crisis it is clear to me
at least that we have an administration
that is largely incompetent and whose
incompetence and recklessness have
threatened the lives of many many people
in our country so today I would like to
give a brief overview of what in my view
we must do to respond to this crisis
first and foremost we are dealing with a
national emergency and the president of
the United States must understand that
and declare that emergency next because
President Trump is unwilling an8 unable
to lead selflessly we must immediately
convene an emergency bipartisan
authority of experts to support and
direct a response that is comprehensive
compassionate and based first and
foremost on science in fact in other
words Congress in a bipartisan manner
must take responsibility for addressing
this unparalleled crisis further we must
aggressively make certain that the
public sector and the private sector are
strongly
cooperating with each other and we need
national and state hotlines staffed with
well trained people who have the best
information available one of the aspects
of the current crisis is there are
people who are asking that's as one of
the symptoms of coronavirus well I have
a cold do I have the flu do I have the
qualifiers who's gonna help me where do
I go to seek medical treatment how do I
get a test when is that test going to be
processed people have a lot of questions
and at the statewide and federal level
we need experts to provide the necessary
information to our people the American
people deserve transparency something
that the current administration has
fought day after day discipled
in other words we need to know what is
happening right now in our country in
our state's and in fact all over the
world if there was ever a time for
transparency and honesty and being
straightforward this is that moment and
we need that information coming from
credible respected scientific voices of
which we have many in our own country
and all over this world not from
politicians and during a crisis we must
make sure that we have for the
communities most vulnerable to the
health and economic pain that is coming
those in nursing homes and
rehabilitation facilities those can find
immigration detention centers those who
are currently incarcerated in in jails
and all people regardless of their
immigration status unfortunately as I
think the American people increasingly
understand our country is at a severe
disadvantage compared to every other
major country on earth because we do not
guarantee health care to all people
they write and as we speak some 87
million Americans are either uninsured
or underinsured and when you are
uninsured or underinsured you hesitate
about getting the medical care you need
because you cannot afford to get that
medical care the result is that millions
of our people cannot afford to go to a
doctor let alone pay for coronavirus
tests so while we work to pass a
medicare-for-all single-payer system the
United States government today must make
it clear that in the midst of this
emergency everyone in our country
regardless of income or where they live
must be able to get all of the health
care they need without cost obviously
when a vaccine or other effective
treatment is developed it must be free
of charge we cannot live in a nation
where if you have the money you get the
treatment you need to survive but if
your working class or poor you get to
the end of the line that would more be
morally unacceptable further we need
emergency funding right now for paid
family and medical leave anyone who is
sick should be able to stay home during
this emergency and receive their
paycheck what we do not want to see it's
at a time when half of our people are
living paycheck to paycheck when they
need to go to work in order to take care
of their family we do not want to see
people going to work who are sick and
who can spread the krona letters we also
need an immediate expansion of community
health centers in this country
so that every American will have access
to a nearby health care facility where
do I go how do I get a test how do I get
the results of that test need greatly to
expand our primary healthcare
capabilities in this country and that
includes expanding community health
centers we need to determine the status
of our testing and processing for the
corona virus the government must respond
aggressively to make certain that we in
fact have the latest and most effective
tests available and the quickest means
of processing those tests there are
other countries around the world who are
doing better than we are in that regard
we should be learning from them no one
none of the medical experts that I have
talked to dispute that there is a major
shortage of ICU units and ventilators
that are needed to respond to this
crisis the federal government must work
aggressively with the private sector to
make sure that this equipment is
available the hospitals and the rest of
the medical community our current health
care system does not have the doctors
and nurses we currently need we are
understaffed during this crisis we need
to mobilize medical residents retired
medical professionals and other medical
personnel to help us deal with this
crisis we need to make sure that doctors
nurses and medical professionals have
the instructions and personal protective
equipment that they need this is not
only because we care about the
well-being of medical professionals but
if they go now then our capability to
respond to this crisis is significantly
diminished the pharmaceutical industry
must be told in no uncertain terms that
the medicines that they manufacture for
this crisis will
sold at cost this is not the time for
price gouging or profiteering the
coronavirus is already causing a global
economic meltdown which is impacting
people throughout the world and in our
own country and it is especially
dangerous for low-income and
working-class families people who today
before the crisis are struggling
economically instead of providing more
tax breaks to the top 1% and large
corporations we need to provide economic
assistance to the elderly and I worry
very much about elderly people in this
country today many of whom are isolated
many of whom do not have a lot of money
we need to worry about those who are
already sick we need to worry about
working families with children people
with disabilities the homeless and all
those who are vulnerable we need to
provide in that context emergency
unemployment assistance to anyone in
this country who loses their job through
no fault of their own right now 23
percent of those who are eligible to
receive unemployment compensation do not
receive it on our proposal everyone who
loses a job must qualify for
unemployment compensation at least 100
percent of their prior salary with a cap
of eleven hundred and fifty dollars a
week was $60,000 a year in addition
those who depend on tips and the
restaurant industry is suffering very
much from the meltdown those who depend
on tips gig workers domestic workers and
independent contractors must also
qualify for unemployment insurance to
make up for the income that they lose
during this crisis we need to make sure
that the elderly people with
disabilities
and families with children have access
to nutritious food that means expanding
the meals-on-wheels program it means
expanding the school lunch program and
snap so that no one goes hungry during
this crisis and everyone who cannot
leave their home can receive nutritious
meals delivered directly to where they
live we need also in this economic
crisis to place an immediate moratorium
on evictions on foreclosures and on
utility shutoffs so that no one loses
their home during this crisis and that
everyone has access to clean water
electricity heat and air conditioning we
need to construct emergency homeless
shelters to make sure that the homeless
survivors of domestic violence and
college students quarantine off campus
are able to receive the shelter the
health care and the nutrition they need
we need to provide emergency lending to
small and medium-sized businesses to
cover payroll new construction of
manufacturing facilities and production
of emergency supplies such as masks and
ventilators a very serious problem right
now in the midst of this crisis here is
the bottom line and that bottom line is
that in the midst of this unprecedented
moment we need to listen to the
scientists to the researchers to the
medical folks not the politicians we
need an emergency response to the
current emergency and we need it
immediately we need more doctors and
nurses in underserved areas we need to
make sure that doc that workers who lose
their jobs in this crisis perceive the
unemployment assistance
they need and in this one in this moment
we need to make sure that in the future
after this crisis is behind us we build
a healthcare system that makes sure that
every person in this country is
guaranteed the health care that they
need
thank you all for going back to
Washington
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Italy is now almost in a full lockdown
all non-essential services will be
halted in the country for the next 15
days now
no more coffees at a bar no more pizzas
no more lunch outside everything is a
shutdown every activities related to
food is shut down the only one open our
bakeries and the groceries so Italian
can still go and buy their favorite
fruits and vegetables can still go to
supermarket actually accounted told
Italians don't rush to buy foods and
goods everything will be available don't
be in a hurry but we already saw several
queues in front of the main supermarkets
on VLAN why because people should stay
at least one meter away away one from
each other so this is creating long a
queue in front of every supermarket as
you can see there is about 100 people
queuing
very orderly everyone
today the fridge was really a peaceful I
had to
you can still buy a cigarette at the
tobacco knees here in Italy those are
one of the few shops which are still
considered sanctioned by the government
you can walk your dog at the park or
just for a limited time and just